[Music]
you'd probably notice if you watched my
videos over the years but I like
whirling I like whirling with extension
I like purling with in spin and I like
whirling with it you spin
I like whirling with everything but
today let's talk about whirling within
spins because it's a nice progression
I'm only going to talk about the arms
and the poi the feet it's a whole
progression consider my online courses
if if you want to really dive into that
but grab your poi and we'll go through
the arms and the poi and like a lot of
things I do it's all about planes so I'm
gonna face this way with you and we're
gonna get our poi going clockwise split
time and we're going to imagine there's
a wall this works the best with the wall
but I always go places where there are
no walls so I'm gonna use the air so you
get your poi split time on your wall
plane and you're going to turn under
your left arm so you have the poi at
your right ear now you're going to start
going further and you're going to want
to do this at the point on this side but
that's not the idea the idea you duck
under your arm the player at your right
ear and then both poil be behind your
head you turn away from your plate so
the big thing is gonna be you're gonna
want to do this keep them here
then your right toy and your right arm
comes up and does a arch over your head
so your pulley are passing each other at
your left ear and then you can turn and
face your play again so your arms go
through a big circle like this and the
poi keep passing each other in the
middle now this takes a while to get
good at it
the you're gonna trouble with the planes
and you're gonna have trouble with the
rhythm I'll do it once facing you I let
I don't need my planes being perfect
because I feel I have to contort my
shoulders a bit I keep my planes pretty
good so I started here I tuck under my
left arm the player up my right ear then
I turn the back of my head to the poi
then I turn my left ear to the poi then
I faced a toy now it took me weeks to be
able to do that with good planes and
good rhythm and slowly I could do it
smoother and smoother and smoother and
then when I could keep the plane and the
rhythm through the whole progression I
found it was fairly straightforward just
to speed it up a bit and do they pass
once in front back the head front in the
head back the head front of it back the
head front back front back front back
and that's all it is so it's a simple
idea and in my experience it took weeks
to make it work smoothly I know some of
you it'll be quicker and some of you
might take longer because everybody
learns differently but once it works
it's just a really nice flow and then
you can go into full extension and you
can reverse your arms in the Aunty spin
that's cetera you get dizzy just do a
spin yeah that I also talked all about
that stuff in my online course and of
course I'll keel bits and pieces in all
the videos I make you'll learn it one
way or the other I hope you're enjoying
yourself wherever you are
um the sun is shining my little flower
gardens are beginning to come up so not
a bad day
[Music]